welcome to today's loss broadcast RNA
I'm success difficult to transfer Excel
by self deliverance and by RNA I am by
the Collegium robbers and I'll be your
moderator for today's arrest you're
delighted to bring you the educational
web seminar presented by rappers and
sponsored by Hanukkah Rock'em healthcare
continues to be the industry leader in
the field of RNAi chemistry RNAi biology
and high-throughput screening and
partners with the RNAi screening
community through participation in the
RNAi global initiative with Dharma Khan
you get access to the largest and most
complete portfolio of innovative and
technologically advanced tools for gene
silencing gene expression and gene
editing for more information please
visit WWE live science calm / dharmic on
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speakers Louise Baskin
and Michael freely Louise Baskin is a
senior product manager at thermicon
having joined the company in 2005 she
holds responsibility for all synthetic
RNA products including custom and
pre-designed SI RNA and micro RNA
reagents Michael freely is a senior
research fellow in the department of
clinical medicine and trinity college
dublin ireland his research focuses on
the cell biology of the t-cell immune
response particularly the signaling
pathways and proteins that regulate t
cell activation and migration I will now
turn it over to our first speaker Louise
Baskin for her presentation Thank You
Brenda for the introduction and thank
you all for joining us today our topic
for the next hour or so will be RNAi
success and difficult to transfect cells
by self delivering SI RNA before we
start we have a very quick polling
question for the group we would like to
know what type of nucleic acid delivery
techniques that you've used before so
please click all that apply to you and
this is kind of helps give us an example
of you know who we've attracted today
and what kinds of things you might learn
I'll leave it open just for a couple
more minutes we'll ever get the chance
again please do click all that apply to
you I will go ahead and close it even
though we're still getting some just
that we can get moving i'll go ahead and
show those results for everyone curious
it's not there we go sorry it's not
letting me show you the results so i
guess we'll just have to look at that
later anyway so for our agenda today i'm
going to be starting with a very brief
overview of how Darmok on addressed
issues with delivery of srna with our
development of xls RNA which is really
going to be the main focus of today's
talk
as part of my section I'll very briefly
introduce a few notable successes that
have been carried out with Excel
applications and now I'll turn it over
to Michael freely who will present some
really great work that he and his lab
have carried out in primary human p
cells and he'll give a more in-depth
look into the details on how they apply
to xls RNA in a screaming environment
for looking at T cell migration since
the advent of RNA interference or RNAi
Dharma Khan's driving passion and focus
has really been around excellence in
RNAi tool development one of our
earliest achievements was in publishing
and commercializing the first set of
rational design rules for functional
srna and this algorithm forms the basis
of all of our si RNA products we also
heavily utilize the two prime ace RNA
synthesis chemistry that Dharma Khan was
founded upon to develop chemical
modification patterns for srna that
address the growing needs of scientists
carrying out RNAi one of our first
modification patterns was si stable
which improves si RNA stability by
preventing s RNA degradation by
nucleases which is particularly useful
when using srna in vivo another key
development was our patented on target
plus modification pattern which improves
si RNA targeting specificity thereby
reducing off targets so today we're
going to focus on a product that was
launched a few years after on target
plus that utilizes aspects of all of
these innovations and it's called excel
SI RNA so even with the advancement in
SI RNA potency and specificity that came
with the growth of RNAi as a mainstream
tool in molecular biology a key issue
remained and that is how can we carry
out SI rna-mediated gene silencing in
cells that are resistant to standard
transfection methods so for years we at
dharma khan had heard from customers who
wanted to work in
biologically relevant cell types things
like beta islet cells cardiomyocytes
primary neurons and p cells we heard
these requests all the time but delivery
of the srna was a huge challenge most SI
RNA experiments are carried out in
transfected cells where standard
cationic lipid transfection agents are
perfectly suitable however many cell
types are highly resistant to or have a
cytotoxic response to transfection
reagent electroporation or nucleus
ection and other instrument based
methods are very useful for a wide range
of cell types but they can cause rather
expensive cell death and the consumables
required like buffers and cuvettes
there's somewhat high amounts of SI RNA
and not to mention the instrument itself
can be rather expensive lentiviral
transduction which delivers shrna rather
than SI RNA is a good option for non
transfected cells plus it gives you the
advantage of creation of stable cell
lines however some cell types have
undesirable responses to viral
transduction and not all labs may have
access to the required BSL two
facilities so the goal in mind when
developing Excel srna was to eliminate
the limitations of these delivery
methods and instead use our RNA
chemistry and cell biology expertise to
create a chemical modification pattern
on the srna itself that enables passive
delivery and particularly enable it to
difficult to transfer cell types now i'm
not going to relive the entire product
development cycle that would just take
much too long instead i will just
summarize the overall approach so first
we wanted to ensure that the srna was
functional so in addition to using our
smart selection algorithm for designing
potent srna we included a modification
which prevents the sense strand of the
srna from loading into risk thereby
increasing the anti sign
or the targeting strand activity second
since these srnas are not being
encapsulated in a transfection reagent
we incorporated modified bases very much
like our SI stable modification to
prevent degradation from nucleases and
lastly and really most importantly we
had to find a way to get these srnas
into cells without the requirement of a
carrier we settled on cholesterol which
as you likely know is a common component
of the lipid bilayer and it's long been
used to introduce oligonucleotides into
cells now what was interesting to us
were the significant differences in
uptake we achieved depending on the type
of linker used to conjugate the
cholesterol to the RNA so the aliphatic
linker that we've settled on gave us
dramatically better delivery than all of
the others that we tested so if you're
curious about any further details on the
RNA chemistry itself please feel free to
look up our patents that cover this
technology in the interest of time I'll
now move on to the application of xls
RNA as i mentioned a big part of our
product development was ensuring that
all of these modifications for delivery
and stability did not interfere with
effective gene knockdown or cause
unwanted cytotoxicity now as you can see
from our early pilot data in these seven
cell lines across a few dozen different
gene targets we were able to achieve
very good target silencing which is
shown by the blue bars showing the level
of knockdown and we maintained very high
cell viability shown by the red dots now
let's talk about how to use excel srna
so the excel delivery protocol can be
broken down into two primary steps but
please keep in mind that thorough
optimization is required just like we
would recommend for any new application
so first the Excel is excuse me to xls
RNA is diluted in low serum or ideally
serum free media to curry
what we call the Excel delivery mix now
what can sometimes confuse our customers
is that we do sell a serum-free media
called Excel delivery media but they
often misunderstand and think that it
contains some special ingredient that is
required for use and that is not the
case nearly any serum-free media or
growth media with its theorem content
adjusted should be fine it's really the
Excel srna itself that enables the
delivery now as for working
concentration typical srna experiments
can be run with anywhere from five to
fifteen Anna molar of srna for Excel we
tend to see best results with two
hundred animal or up to one micromolar
of srna now while that might seem
alarmingly high to those of you
accustomed to using transfection reagent
in hela cells for example remember that
this is a totally different molecule
using passive delivery which is
generally less efficient than other
methods so the amount that actually gets
into the cell when working at one
micromolar is very similar to what you
would see with conventional srna being
delivered by transfection agents at a
lower concentration now once you've
worked through the appropriate
conditions for the delivery mix you
simply add it to yourself now here's
where we see another deviation from
standard a siren a transfection we do
recommend a longer time point prior to
asking for knockdown for instance with
standard transfection we can typically
see mrna knockdown by 24 to 48 hours but
with Excel we push that out to 72 to 96
hours and even longer for protein
detection again this is a difference due
to that passive delivery the overall
duration of silencing will still be the
same around four to six days and you can
add serum containing media back to your
cells after about 48 hours if they're
showing some sensitivity so now that
I've given you a very high-level idea of
how to use excel srna
I want to show you a few examples of
excel in action now the examples I chose
our all-new ronal cell models but please
do keep in mind that many different cell
types have been successfully used with
xls RNA so this first example is an
experiment that was carried out in the
early days of excel as a proof of
principle primary neurons were one of
the cell types that we heard about a lot
from customers in terms of the
limitations they were running into with
use of SI RNA so we worked with a group
that was wanting to use primary neurons
as a cellular model for Alzheimer's
disease however again delivery of srna
to these primary neurons was really an
obstacle for them so this slide provides
an overview of the protocol that was
used so in the upper left you'll see the
types of Excel labeled and non labeled
controls that were used as well as an
Excel smart pool reagent targeting p53
which is being assessed as a positive
control these were combined with neuro
basil media with a b27 supplement and
then were then added to rat cortical
neurons so this use of neuro basil media
is a perfect example of a serum-free
media that would be used for growing
these cells anyway so the addition of
xls RNA to the experiment was really not
very disruptive they've been incubated
the neurons for two different time
points and then assessed for uptake of
the Excel srna by visual inspection of
the labeled controls and they also
assayed for target gene mrna knockdown
so first we'll look at how did labeled
XL read srna controlled localized in the
treated cells as you can see in panels a
and B both the wide and the DA and see
the wide and the detailed views
virtually all of the neurons were
positive for uptake of the Excel read
control and that uptake was really
throughout the cell body and out into
the new rights next I looked at p53
knock down on the mRNA level as you can
see at the 48-hour time point there was
a reduction of p53 by
over sixty percent now this is a
somewhat early time point based on what
we would now recommend for
excel.application it would be expected
to knock down would be even greater at a
later time point now while there was
still a fair amount of optimization to
be done these researchers were able to
conclude that Excel would permit them to
carry out these functional target
validation studies in primary cortical
neurons and this is a cell type that had
been unusable in this manner up until
this point next up is a very similar
protocol but this time their researchers
were working in organotypic brain slices
so this is a model that permits
investigators to maintain all of the
cell types within a heterogeneous tissue
and it more closely models the in vivo
cellular circuitry but in a more
convenient ex vivo environment so in
this study again an early proof of
principle for this interesting but
difficult to transect tissue model our
collaborators incubated mouse brain
slices in Excel controls that were
diluted and this time they used Excel
delivery media but they did add the B
27-year onal supplement they then
carried out both visual analysis to
verify a pic of the labeled control as
well as Western blot analysis to look at
protein level of the target gene so here
are photos from eight hours and 72 hours
post application of the labeled xls RNA
and you can see after 72 hours and
culture fluorescence in the slices was
much more intense really indicated an
increased uptake of the Excel srna into
the deeper layers of the tissue with
that extended incubation the Western
blot analysis was similarly encouraging
as you can see in the upper right
cyclophilin be showed significant
depletion at the protein level by the 96
our time point so as with the primary
neurons this is a very encouraging
demonstration of Excel srna enabling
gene knockdown in this difficult to
transect tissue model
my last example is from a much more
recent publication and I think really
highlights this culmination of successes
in the other neuronal systems that came
before so this group from the University
of Guelph in Ontario carried out a study
of DNA methyltransferases and their
impact on object memory processing they
did this by selectively knocking down
three different d nmt with xls RNA in
different regions of the brain and then
assessing their subjects to object in
place learning the shrna was delivered
via a cannula to either the hippocampus
or the Paranal cortex now I cannot
possibly do justice to the entire
breadth of this paper I would encourage
you to reference the full article for
details I do just want to point out two
data points that highlight the xls RNA
results specifically the targeted mRNA
knockdown and how they were able to
correlate that knock down to the
behavioral assessment of the subjects so
this first figure shows the mRNA
knockdown levels at 48 hours after a
single dose of Excel srna to the ca
region of the hippocampus so the CA
region was isolated and the MRNA levels
for each of the indicated DN mt targets
was assessed so as you can see there was
a very good discrimination between the
three different family members and very
good knockdown levels overall and now
here's one of many examples from the
paper of how targeted knockdown impacted
the behavioral phenotype so in subjects
that were treated with Excel srna
targeting in this case dnmt3a there is
virtually no difference in their
long-term memory formation immediately
following srna administration and so
that's what's shown in the bars on the
left but 24 hours after administration
as you can see from the bars on the
right so that there is significant
impairment observed in the subjects that
were treated with XL targeting dnmt3a
compared to the control
very similar results were also seen at
the 48-hour time point demonstrating to
this group that Excel srnas were active
in vivo both one and two days following
the administration there have been many
other published successes with Excel
srna and Bebo and we're very happy to
continue to see these results where it's
used for a successful in vivo target
validation so that brings me to the end
of my portion of today's webinar I'll
turn it over to Michael in just a moment
hopefully you've gained aid an initial
understanding of xls RNA how it's
delivered to cells by way of chemical
modifications rather than transfection
reagent for anyone interested in giving
Excel a try it is available pre-designed
for human mouse and rat you simply
search for your gene on our website if
you're working in a different species we
can apply XL modifications by way of
custom synthesis so very easy to get
this for nearly any species you might be
working in so without any further delay
I want to get to what I consider to be
the most interesting part of the webinar
today Michael freely is going to discuss
a screen that his team carried out in
primary T cells using Excel SI RNA okay
thank you very much Louise and so the
title of my talk today is RNAi screening
for identification of genes that
regulate primary human cheats of
migration so T fields play a very
important role in defense against
pathogens and tumors and one of the
cornerstones of immunology and the
course of t-cells is that they can
discriminate between non cells such as
the pathogen and tumor and cells tissues
however in some patients this
discrimination between self and non-self
can be lost and this can lead to
inflammatory disease are autoimmune
disease as well as that unregulated
t-cell proliferation can lead to many
chiefs and leukemias and t-cell
lymphomas Hurons last but not least the
GFL eight the size of infection by the
HIV virus and this is a global problem
still today shin so really understanding
the genes and signaling pathways that
regulate t-cell function
is very important from both a basic
biological viewpoint and also found the
therapeutic standing so one of the ways
we can understand the function of genes
in t cells is via silencing of gene
expression approach using SI RNAs now
primary t cells are known as how its
transfect and that's because their
suspension cells and they're not very
transfected with lipid mediated
transfection reagents so that's that
creates a problem so to the most and
common methods of delivery of shrnas
into T cells is electroporation and
nuclear faction or viral vectors
electroporation creates transient pores
in the plasma membrane of the tree so
and this allows ESI RNAs to traverse
into the cytoplasm and cause the
silencing of gene expression however an
ortho side effect of this
electroporation is the loss of cell
viability the second most common method
of delivery or viral vectors and this is
where the SAR nada encoded in the genome
of the virus as a short hairpin RNA and
subsequent incubation of the virus with
the chi fel allows the shrna to be
expressed in the g sell some of common
methods of sa RNA delivery to primary T
cells are conjugation of the essay RNA
to a peptide of protein to nanoparticles
or to Optimus which enable efficient
delivery of the essay RNA into T cells
and that's but not least as we've
introduced the new player in the market
are dharmic on Excel shrnas and these
are chemically modified srnas that enter
into cells without the need of it for a
transfection reagent and for those of
you who are interested we recently
reviewed the methods of SI RNA delivery
into T cells and for both applications
inflammatory disease cancer and
infection
so with the discovery of RNAi and the
development of RNAi libraries and this
really transformed the field as it
enables rapid and unbiased novel gene
discovery application processes to come
to the fore and this 50 slide summarizes
all of the SI or any screens that have
been done in t cells today in vitro and
many of these assays they focused on and
genes regulating in a kappa b activation
for example gene regulation t cell
migration and also genes regulating and
t-cell proliferation and survival
however what you notice from all of
these screens don today is that they all
use either needs affection and
electroporation or lentiviral vectors to
carry out these screens and just creates
a major problem and because of course
and carrying out an RNAi screen is such
a such a big way and requires scale up
and and this is not very easy when using
reagents like nuclear affection or
lentiviral vectors for example abusive
nuclear affection for RNAi screening
requires multi-well electric razors and
the course as I mentioned earlier you
can get lots of cell viability with this
as well as that using lentiviral vectors
requires expertise knowledge and
biosafety level was to carry out these
screens and again this is not very easy
another point I'd like to make is that a
lot of these screens used transformed T
cell lines such as the jerk achieve
failed to carry out these screens and
it's well known that your kerchief cells
Harbor many mutations and in
distributing pathways and thereby
they're not reflective of primary human
t cells it's really a major advance in
the field would be to be able to perform
or any I screens easily in primary human
t cells using much easier methods of
delivery order their nuclear Fechner
lentiviral vectors so our research is
focused on the molecular mechanism of T
cell migration and activation so for T
cells to become activated they must
migrate from the bloodstream into
secondary lymphoid organs such as a
spleen or lymph node where they reach
antigen presenting cells and the first
step in this cascade is the arrest of CT
cell on the blood vessel rod this arrest
is mediated by chemokines which are
immobilized on the surface event
clean yourselves near the entry point to
the lymph node or spleen and these
chemokines signal through their cognate
kingkahn receptor expressed on T cells
and different uses a rapid intracellular
signaling cascade that converts and
adhesion receptors such as the immigrant
lfa-1 from a low affinity to a high
affinity confirmation and this
conformational change another state one
permits the t-cell to bind to its
counter ligand icam-1 which is also
expressed on the surface of the
endothelial cell and the fifth cascade
dash enables t-cell arrest and the blood
vessel wall as well as that and
integrins searched lfa-1 can signal
bi-directionally such that the ligand
bound form of lfa-1 can signal back into
the T cell and this can cause a
memorization and redistribution of the
cytoskeleton and T cells and this
results in a functional change in the
shape of T cells and they they change
shape from around vertical shape to a
tad port like morphology and to start
actively migrating along the blood
vessel world until such time as that
Dimitra suitable entry size into the
secondary lymphoid organs once within
the lymphoid organs they follow chemical
gradients until they meet the antigen
presenting cells which will be
presenting and observe as part of the
pathogen over the course a number of
days that he fell may become activated
and differentiation into what is known
as an effector T cell and these T cells
have new properties for example effector
cd4 t-cells acquired ability to secrete
distinct inflammatory cytokines for is
an effector cd8 t-cells now acquired the
property to kill and directly killed
target cells infected target cells and
tissues as well as that the t-cell
Wanted's in the lymph node that must be
able to migrate from death lymph node
back into the bloodstream and into do
peripheral tissues where the pathogen
was first encountered so a similar
mechanism for migration into these
peripheral tissues such as the skin and
gastrointestinal tract is also mediated
by chemokines and insurance such as
lfa-1
so in our lab we have a model of t cell
migration and that's where why we take
primary human cd3 t cells and we
activate them over the course of a
number of days with photo hemagglutinin
and they t cell growth factor
interleukin 2 and this pre activation
mimics chief cell activation in lymph
nodes by antigen presenting cells and
those who generate effector T cell
populations we then take the cells and
we incubate them and recombinant I can
usually in the presence of an
immobilized chemo coin and this
stimulates the t cell polarization that
I talked about previously as well as
that we have another model whereby we
take a crosslinking anti lfa-1 antibody
and mobilizes on the surface of a place
and placing the effector T cells on the
substrate also introduces T cell
polarization so we can make videos of
this T cell polarization and now I'm
going to show you a video of what
actually happens when we track the cells
using the Intel analyzer and also
microscopy
you
so I hope everybody was able to see that
chief of migration video you can see DT
so it's actively migrating over the
substrate of the place so we were
interested in trying to identify novel
genes regulating T cell migration so
with that in mind we wanted to perform
some RNAi screening are some libraries
to identify genes that regulate this
process I want to start it out in this
field we we we came into the usual
problems of the RNAi delivery into
primary human t cells for example we
have to decide would we use
electroporation or we'll use viral
vectors to deliver the RNAi library into
T cells and luckily about that time
dharmic on released their axle or an AI
technology and across the exact cell
assay RNA they're available in library
format so we wanted to use an ax LS air
and a library as a proof of principle
strategy to identify genes involved in
lfa-1 mediated t cell migration in
primary human t cells and the working on
to describes you today was just recently
accepted in the journal of volume
molecular screening so we received an
axial essay on a library and from Dharma
con and this robbery was a small affair
in a library targeting seventy two
distinct genes now these SI rnase in the
place were smart food as I rnase so they
consisted of four distinct SI rnase
targeting each distinct messenger RNA in
the south and the library was configured
to target a variety of intracellular
signaling pathways and this library
played nap in light blue for example
shows the kinase which were targeted
shown here as well as that under place
there was an essay or na targeting the G
hydrogenated gasp eh so as an SI or na
targeting the small GT pas real way and
importantly I when dunno be screening
yells add to negative controls so we had
a non targeting as I or n a pool in
excel format as well as the four
individual SI RNA is non targeting pools
from this mark flew in addition we also
had a fluorescently labeled or fan
labels SI RNA targeting PPI be
if reagent use will use as a useful
reagent to monitor fa RNA delivery into
the primary human t cells so after we
received the Excel library from Dharma
Khan if was received in a dried down
format at one animal or Excel shrna /
well we added 100 microliters of the
Dharma countess arna buffer and to each
well of the platians masturbation and
this gave the concentration of 10 micro
molar SI RNA / well then using a
handheld pipette we produce ten dollar
plates from this library each with 10
microliters of the Excel sa RNA pro well
and these were stored at minus 20 until
the library screening procedure as we've
described earlier and adding the XXL SI
rnase to yourselves is quite easy you
just resuspend yourselves at the
required concentration in delivery
medium and just the excel sa RNA after
incubating the cells for a required
period of time you can measure things
like delivery of the axial srnas by flow
cytometry or confocal you can analyze
knockdown of a target gene of interest
biking PC or a restaurant blood and/or
you can measure a cellular phenotype so
we did something like this but because
our brother set or sa RNAs were already
on the place we actually just added our
t cells in excel delivery medium
directly to the SAR and a daughter
location and details were resuspended at
the recommended concentration by Darma
can have 2 million cells per mil and
after incubating the cells with the
library for 72 hours at 37 degrees we
did all of these assays we looked at
delivery of the xls I rnase by saw
cytometry in confocal microscopy we
monitored knockdown of target genes by
qpcr and western blush and we also
importantly looked at a cellular
phenotype in our case they t cell
polarization on anti lfa-1 using an
image-based high content analysis
platform so the first part of the work
we did after we transfected the cells
with the axilla ceranae library was to
confirm delivery of the essay RNAs into
the cells and as I mentioned earlier one
of the essay rnase in the library was a
fam labeled sa RNA targeting the PPI be
so we have stood cells from this place
and we wash them and analyzing by flow
cytometry and you can see here on this
and histogram plot on the left that one
hundred percent of the primary human t
cells were transfected with the family
but ppi BSI RNA for is on the right this
is the negative control which is a non
labeled as a RNA targeting PPI be just
to show the background fluorescence
levels this showed that the essay rnase
were taking up into the T cells when we
submitted this work we actually hired a
question from a reviewer who wanted to
know where the essay RNA is just stuck
to the outside of the cells and of
course this could lead to a false
positive result in flow cytometry so to
address this question we also looked at
Excel green SI RNAs which like the fam
labels ppi be can be used for success
earlier ization studies so we treated
transfected t cells with the Excel green
srnas and this time we fix them and
stain them with both a antibody to the
LSA one immigrant in red here and you
can see here the Excel green SI RNA by
confocal microscopy n looking at dead
stacks of the cells are clearly
delivered into the cytoplasm of primary
human t cells where it's on the right
here shows a connective control
experiment whereby T cells are incubated
with a non labeled controllers RNA which
has no fluorescence just provides
background and reference control under
course Steve SI Oren aids were up taken
into primary human t cells as well by
flow cytometry axial green sa RNA so the
first question we addressed the second
question was to verify knockdown of a
target gene by either qpc or western
blotting and as i mentioned earlier one
of DSA rnase in the library targeted dth
molecule so we harvested d cells and
after simply two hours we could see that
the SAR na Targon GAF dth resulted in
approximately seventy percent knockdown
of the target gene after messenger RNA
level in comparison to control
experiment setup they were treated with
an excel non targeting controller
ceranae or kitty cells
non treated with NES arenado's again is
a very positive result the last part of
the study we looked at in the screening
assay was to look at the cellular
phenotype and in our case the change in
cell shape from a round shape to this
polarized T cell morphology and we use
an image-based high content analysis to
monitor this screening so after 22 hours
approximately twenty percent of the
cells in the library were taken out from
the library place and incubated on an
immobilized anti lfa-1 antibody and
these cells were allowed to develop a
polarized morphology similar to the
video that you hopefully saw earlier the
cells were then fixed with per mile hike
and stained with a hook stain to label
the nucleus and antibody targeting
tubulin linked to fitc fluorescent
molecule in green to label be alpha
tubulin cytoskeleton and also the cells
were labeled with phalloidin linked to
TR ITC to label filamentous actin and
here you can see representative image
from the MCL analyzer and showing the
polarized T cells of course to quantify
the streets on morphology we did not see
this by hand so we used an Intel
analyzer from GE Healthcare to both
acquire and analyze these images and
this is very important because to
screening an image analysis procedure
allowed us to quantify roughly H 10,000
cells per well which is very important
you do knockdown experiments to show
that you need to cover a cell population
in your analysis and not just cherry
picks themselves against align legs are
allowed us to you automatically acquire
all of these images and it also allowed
us to analyze the cell morphology in an
automated manner as well which I'll
explain in the next slide so for those
of you who are not familiar with the
Intel analyzer it detects cells by
nuclear dye uptake shown here and it
measures the morphology of cells based
on a number of cellular stains that you
can use so in our case we had stained
the cells within antibody to as the
tubulin and Floyd into your ITC to label
the filamentous actin so we based at T
cell morphology analysis and both of
these chains
and of course there's many ways to
measure teeth on morphology but for she
sells we routinely use for morphology
parameters which we've previously shown
in a publication to be most informative
for analyzing T cell shape and I go
through some of these the most important
one that we we find is the one over form
factor parameter which is a 1 over
roundness index and we find that as T
cells polarized migrate from around
sparkly shape to a polarized elongation
morphology that the one over form factor
parameter increases and it's a brutal
readouts of T cell migration the second
parameter that we use is nuclear
displacement and this measures the
position of the nucleus relative to the
center of the cell body so in non
migration or non polarized T cells the
nucleus is usually found localized in
the center of the cell so it's not
displaced from the cell body however in
t cells that are actively migrating the
nucleus migrate and it moves to the
front of the cell and away from the
center of the cell body and thereby a
nuclear displacement also increases we
also use the generic morphology
parameter cell area which also increases
jaunty cell migration and the cell
generation radius which measures this
thread of cell and all of these
parameters increased as well so they're
good readouts of T cell migration the
infill analyzer also comes with number
of fluorescent intensity parameters
which allowed us to measure the
fluorescence intensity of either they
are for tubulin or the filamentous actin
stain and this was mediated by the I XA
+ + C parameter as well as that we also
included some other informative
parameters such as intensity spreading
which allows you to measure the amount
of staining your the cell boundary as
well as the cell intensity Phoebe
parameter which allows you to check how
homogenous you're staining is inside the
cells and these again were useful
readouts of T cell morphology so we
performed three or any ice creams using
T cells from independent owners and we
identified as I RNAs that affected the
various T cell morphology parameters
using exam score system so if those of
you who are not familiar with Zed score
it's a common statistical method for
analysis of high-throughput screens and
it expresses a sample value as the
distance
from the mean in multiples of standard
deviations so we defined the effects of
srnas has been statistically significant
only if they exceeded that score
threshold plus 20 minus 2 in three hours
to three screens we displayed the dead
score data as a heat map shown here on
the left and the dead score data was I
wanted to say to the heat map and they
were colored so SI rnase within that
score of minus 2 or greater who were
colored in green well as I rnase with a
dead score of plus 2 or greater were
colored in red I from the three screens
performed you can see here quite clearly
that the essay RNA targeting a small
GTA's relay if increased be dead scores
for t cells migrating on Angie lfa-1
whereas because the one over form factor
and the nuclear displacement parameter
was increased for both the tubulin and
the filamentous actin stain so this
indicates to us on the screen that once
we treat ourselves with the essay or na
targeting relay the detailed elongated
relative to all that our samples on the
place and the visual inspection of the
row a treated cells shown here show that
these cells had elongated tails relative
to the control SI RNAs which is a nice
result as well as that and our farm
labels ppi BSA RNA although not
affecting any of the Chiefs and
morphology parameters it did increase
the fluorescence intensity parameters
particularly only of the alpha tubulin
stain and this makes sense because the
alsa tubulin stain is in green and
therefore when these cells are also
treated with a family of the ppi B which
is also in green this increases the
fluorescence intensities this confirmed
the essay RNA delivery to the primary
human t cells and complements the
studies we showed using flow cytometry
and confocal microscopy after performing
the three screens railway was one of the
hips from that library and however you
may notice that we only use twenty
percent of these cells from the library
for the migration assay and of course an
advantage of using suspension cells such
as primary T cells in your neck or any
eye screening applications it's
the remainder of cells can be used for
additional assays without requiring
extensive manipulation such as
trypsinization so because we had quite a
few cells left over we use the remainder
cells for for additional assays these
acids were cell viability whereby we
added cell charger blue reagent to
twenty percent of the cells we also
measure total cell count using a high
content analysis procedure again
staining the cells with the nucleotide
hoaxed 3325 asian and we also measured
adhesion of the cells following knock
down to icam-1 either in the absence or
presence of the key makinde sdf-1 and
this is important because it asian of t
cells is the step that occurs prior
tumor to migration so we also wanted to
look at onion tagines affected this
process so this slide summarizes the SI
RNA screens you can be sad or blue
celtics total cell count and effusion
assets that we did and again we use the
veg score threshold to define hits so
we're looking for anything that close to
reminds to and as a hitch and however we
did not find any dsrnas affected any of
these parameters in these assays so
there's no hits from these particular
screens so going back to our migration
assay we identified SI rnas are in row a
and we found that they affected the key
cell migration and so with that we had
to validate this work so you can t cells
from independent donors we transaction
with the control SI RNA or an fi RNA
smart proven targeting railway and after
simcha to our of the cells were
harvested and lived and then I probed by
western blotting with an antibody
specific for away and you you should be
able to see there on the top panel that
and railway was knocked down by the row
a smart pool after 72 hours as well as
that we also looked at be four
individual SI rnase from that railway
smarticle to test whether if each or all
of these hadn't effect on the railway
expression levels and we found that 304
SI or na is shown here resulted in
knockdown of railway expression row a
tyranny number four was the least
effective in our hands and
quantification of the relay knockdowns
from five independent donors
and showed that the SI RNA is targeting
railway resulted in approximately eighty
to ninety percent knockdown of railway
at the Western block level in our hands
of course once we knock down railway we
had to show that these cells would
elongate more relative to controls so
again I had the same self from these
Western blush experiments were plated on
an anti lfa-1 antibody shown in the
black bears here or as a negative
control the relation on poly-l-lysine
which induces T cell adhesion but those
Martian juice and the migration
phenotype and hope I can show you there
that the row asio RNA treating tease us
with their away FR na induced an
elongation morphology using the wound
over form factor parameter relative to
the control as a RNA treated cells are
non transected cells as well as that the
three of the four SI rnase here
targeting row a also produced a similar
phenotype of increased T cell
polarization and a very identical result
was also seen when nuclear displacement
parameter was chosen as the morphology
read of instead of 10 / form factor so
knocking down Rahway induces an
elongation phenotype and this next slide
shows some of the images from the Intel
analyzer so these cells again had been
stained with phalloidin TR ITC and as a
tubulin green and hope you can see in
these images that the elongated tales of
the T cells once railway had been a
warrant or a row a expression had been
suppressed and this was evident through
both the snark who's targeting away and
the individual SiO Renee's as well this
next slide shows the level of or a row a
silencing karlax with cellular phenotype
and so basically i'll just take it
through this here and you can see here
this is the percent level of row a
silencing of the really smart cruise
giving about 80% knock down and the
morphology of that cell she was
elongated phenotype in terms of nuclear
displacement relative to controls and
similarly three of the four SI RNAs that
resulted in knockdown giving about
eighty percent nocturne
also increased the nuclear displacement
parameter however the essay RNA number
for targeting relay which gave the least
effective knock down that produced the
least effective phenotype in terms of
nuclear displacement this is a clear
correlation between the degree of
silencing of rho e and the phenotype so
I haven't shown you today some live cell
imaging experiments that we did when we
knocked down low a or using the Intel
analyzer we could clearly show that once
T cells were depreciate over away using
the Excel SI RNAs and that these cells
failed to migration and we could clearly
see that the tales of these cells were
stuck on the substrate and the anti
lfa-1 substrate and while the leading
edge was capable of moving forward the
tail of the cell was stuck to the place
we wanted to see how does this translate
into in terms of T cell migration so we
tracked the speed of the cells that
their migration over the anti lfa-1
substrate and this is quantified here in
this next slide and it shows that
knocking down railway expression with
the axe LSA RNA decreases hgcl speed and
anti lfa-1 in parallel experiments we
also looked at the ability of t cells to
migrate through a porous filter poker
with icam-1 towards the key looking in
the bottom of the transwell and using t
cell donors from four independent
experiments we were clearly able to show
that knockdown over away using the smart
food as I or an area to decrease the
ability of the cells to migrate through
a filter thereby showing that row is
required for T cell migration in vitro
notice this point we had a knockdown
away and flash the cells on an anti
lfa-1 antibody so we also wanted to
check well would you see a similar
phenotype when if we played the cells
under physiological ligand icam-1 so we
did this experiment so and the cells
which have row a knockdown are in black
bears where's the controller Serenade
g-sensor to light bars and we place the
sales an anti lfa-1 it's expected t
cells elongation and we also played the
cells under physiological ligand icon
won t cells and elongation as well
in parallel we wants to see what with
the polarization of t-cells like on
other internal organs for example in
Finnegan's that are specific for beetle
one entrance and similar to migration rd
and LSA one ligand icam-1 we found that
migration of t-cells and both vcam-1 and
fibronectin was increased once railway
was knocked down there for railway is
required for vibration on multiple
t-cell ligands so going back to my first
slide I told you that T cells are
important for a defense against tumors
and pathogens they're involved in
inflammatory disease an autoimmune
disease and nearly two t-cell leukemia
is and informers and there are four the
site infection by HIV so think we're d
excel or any eye screening technology
will have great applications will be in
all of these types of assays for example
and some are any ice creams have been
done in t cells today's positive
primarily use jerk at chi cells to
transform T cell line so I think being
able to perform a screen in the primary
human t-cell we really have to drive
this field forward so in summary we've
demonstrated feasibility and
applicability of excel s Erin a library
screening in primary human t cells we
sure that there's no specialist
equipment required such as multiwell
facial expirations or you don't need any
expert knowledge in viral vectors and
for the delivery of these srnas into
primary human t cells we show that the
axial shrnas are efficiently delivered
into the cells resulting robust
silencing of gene expression and
importantly they're available in library
format for RNAi screening studies and
from our screening study using the
library targeting 72 testing genes we
identified her away from this library
screen as a crucial regulator of T cell
polarity and migration we also showed
that multiple assays can potentially be
performed from a single only our library
screen and this increases the
comprehensive biological readouts that
can be performed from a single screen
and of course d screens are these assays
can be coupled with the Excel library
and another plate based assays for
example Eliza assays to measure for
example in terms of Chiefs of cytokine
production transvaal assays to monitor T
cell migration as we have shown here in
imaging assay using
an image-based high content analysis
platform while they can also be coupled
with various gene expression reporter
assays using fluorescent or luminescence
based methods or other signaling assets
such as calcium flux Swift thought I'd
just like to thank everyone for
listening today I'd like to thank
everybody who's involved in this work
from both trinity college and from
Dharma con so thank you very much thank
you for those interesting and
informative presentations while we are
getting ready for the Q&A session two
polling questions will be appearing on
your screen and we would appreciate your
answers to these questions so that we
may follow up appropriately with you
thank you during the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question from our
audience is there any information on
efficiency of excel SI RNA in activated
T cells
could you repeat that question again
there please certainly is there any
information on the efficiency of excel
SI RNA in activated t-cells yeah well
the data I show today was all activated
t-cells and so we're able to show one
hundred percent delivery of the essay
RNA into T cells and in terms of non
activated t-cells there is a lot of data
out there as well in terms of the use of
excel SI rnase for these cell types in
terms of knockdown efficiency and also
delivery and we have reviewed some of
these studies in our biochemical journal
publication in 2013 friend who is
interested thank you our next question
96 hours of incubation is there a need
to change the medium once I'll go ahead
and take that one so I I did see in the
QA there's a lot of questions about
incubation times and the the serum
requirement so I'll try to address a lot
of them in this response so the first
thing I want to point out is that the
reason that we require serum free or low
serum conditions it's not a stab
stability problem with the srna the
problem is that the BSA in serum will
bind up the cholesterol on the xls RNA
and really prevent it from getting into
the cell so we really need to reduce
that during the time that Excel is
working on getting in if that makes
sense so we we when we say low serum our
own testing showed that serum up to
about two and a half two maybe three
percent was still not interfering with
knockdown enough but did boost the cell
viability in cells that were a little
more sensitive to those low serum
conditions that's going to be very cell
type dependent but the recommendations
you'll see in our protocol will say two
and a half or just less than three
percent we we have shown and many
publications have shown that adding
serum containing media back at 48 hours
so if you have a need for a media change
anyway you can use serum containing
media because by that 48-hour time point
we are able to know that the srna is
getting in but we just need to wait we
typically do recommend again though that
72 hours or more before you actually
look at knockdown so hopefully that
answered again so much of this is just
as you would do with any new experiment
you have to optimize you have to make
sure that your cell density your cell
type is balanced out with the type of
results you're getting from the XL
knockdown great our next question have
you done excel SI RNA in the knee or
cartilage of the mice oh that is a great
question we ourselves have not done that
I am almost positive that another group
did do a delivery to I want to say it
was to the gums of rat to actually do a
periodontal model we do have over 70
references available online that are
kind of sorted and characterized by cell
type or in vivo cell model that's a
great reference if the one I'm thinking
of is not on the list i will get back to
that person specifically with the
reference i'm thinking of our next
question what can be the highest
concentration of sirum in the Excel
delivery of media a good question i may
have answered that with my earlier
response again you can add as much serum
as you might need to be excel media but
we do recommend three percent or less to
avoid interfering with the excel
delivery itself our next question how
did the t cells respond to the serum
preconditions for excel delivery were
the conditions difficult to optimize
I know and the conditions weren't
difficult optimize it all and we just
resuspend the cells in the Excel
delivery medium now we were using
activated t-cells so when we routinely
culture activated t-cells we add
interleukin-2 in the medium so we added
introduced into in the medium during the
knockdown period and so we saw no loss
of cell viability during this period
thank you our next question are you
planning any additional screens yeah
I'll take that one again and we hope to
be in the future and depending on
funding we would like to do as some
larger screens with access library so
yes for sure great thank you another
question can I use excel with
electroporation or lipofectamine to
improve transfection efficiency that's a
good question i think that one came in
early on maybe before we got into some
of the details so Excel srna of course
could be used with a transfection agent
or with electroporation or some other
instrument based technology but that's
sort of like putting your car in the
back of a semi to drive it it's really
not necessary you're not going to get
improved results from either of those
other delivery technologies because of
the Excel Excel really works on its own
kind of as naked RNA getting into the
cell itself so you could use it but
there's no reason to not just use
conventional unmodified srna for
transfection reagent or electroporation
use great thank you and we have time for
one last question we have it here it is
if it's sometimes required to add Excel
repeatedly during the experiment
duration for an optimal k down oh that's
a great question one of the things that
we tested
early on that I did not really have time
to work into the presentation was that
we were able to get extended duration
knockdown by repeatedly treating the
cells with XL so it was sort of in every
other media change we added back Excel
and we were able to get knocked down out
to 20 or even 30 days there's a
publication on that's in our references
where they got 10-day duration knockdown
in primary neurons so it's not
necessarily going to give you stronger
knockdown by repeatedly dosing but
because it is so gentle to the cells you
are able to get a longer duration of
silencing by repeatedly adding it back
to the media thanks so much that's all
the time we have two questions I just
like to let our audience know if you
submitted a question true the Q&A button
and it was not answered someone will get
that to you regarding your inquiry if
you have further questions that you did
not submit during this broadcast please
email them to the Donna com team at TS
thermicon at GE com and some will be
happy to assist you I would like to
thank our speakers Louise Baskin and
Michael freely as well as our sponsor
dharmic on for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 12 2015 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
miss today's live event thank you very
much see you next time goodbye